All right, so both of these forces are going to perfectly balance each other out.
We know that the electric force is going to exactly equal to gravitational force,
and we know the formulas for both of these forces, so we can put those in,
and you'll see that the distance between the two particles immediately cancels out,
and the charges for both of our particles are both 1 coulomb,
so we know that this product of charges is just going to be equal to one,
so I'm just going to cross that out, and since both of these two particles have the same mass,
we know that the product m₁m₂ here is just equal to m².
This gives us the equation K=Gm², and solving for m here, we find that the mass
has to be equal to the √K/G which plugging our known values for these two constants,
we get that the mass has to be 1.16*10¹⁰ kg and that is a really large mass.
To give you something to compare this to, this is about twice the mass
of one of the Egyptian pyramids and that's just if our particles have a charge of 1 Coulomb.
To balance out the electric force between two particles with a relatively small charge,
we need a giant mass, and this tells us one of two things,
either that the gravitational force is really, really, really weak in comparison to the electric force
or most of the masses we deal with in everyday life are really, really, really small.
Either way, it helps us put these two forces in perspective.